foreign
thank you very much yes I'm not the
youngest in the room today
so a bit of taipai thing here so type by
comes from a snake another snake called
Taipan which is an Aussie snake
Australian snake which is very fast
so we mixed it with python that's the
the story behind it
um so yeah we did work for about 30
years in the building large AI
application for large industry when we
were in a company called ilog and later
on as part of IBM
the story is that we decided a few years
back to stop developing in Java on C
plus plus so I'm ready to move into type
into python
so
that's how type I started
we noticed so the initial thinking when
we decided to build type I by the way
type I is a python package in fact it
contains two different packages that
have nothing to do with each other
type I GUI and type I core
we wanted to build a package that was
you know able to do simple data
presentation all the way to more complex
algorithms and not only machine learning
you've got a lot of other algorithms
that exist here
that you can use it for
but we basically felt on a lot of the
application we were building in those
days until till now actually for end
users so of course there's a data
scientist or somebody that builds the
algorithm the pipeline the algorithm the
code
but behind it on most of the application
we were looking at for four end users
okay and there's a very good talk I
would like you to go to if you have time
to listen to a tech Ted Talk by Andrew
who presented basically this thing you
know it's not only about automated AI
you've got all these big guys that build
all these automated AI stuff on the
other hand of the spectrum you got a
little gross arrows trying to predict
something it's very customized doesn't
have a lot of money and you have a whole
range of business in between this is
really where we were doing business in
the past
so
one thing we noticed also that a lot of
the pilots developed in Python stayed
pilot
they were not able to move to the next
stage that's a number that in fact comes
from Gartner
but that's also something that that we
wanted to change in the companies that
were
either into python or going into python
and the reasons for this is there are
many many reasons for for this situation
a lot of it has to do with
um lack of resources in the I.T world
for recruitment difficulty also to
unit specialist for instance you build
an algorithm then you need a graphical
guide JavaScript guy a devop guy
data engineer data scientist data and so
on so you end up basically with this an
initial
pilot that this company built for 10K
fairly cheap
then
the full app was cost down basically
600k to develop
um so you can they cannot do a lot of
projects based on this
so in this case they did an RFP so this
is one of the largest retailer in France
called enter Marche
so this is an RFP for a cash flow
prediction application for the CFO on
the treasurers these were the end users
here
it cost them that so they they basically
hire the company to do the job eight
four people for eight months
at the same time in parallel they use
type by they did the same thing on the
the customer had could choose between
which version you prefer the prefer this
one and that's the software that is
currently working
and it was done for about 60k with 1.5
people
okay so that means that this company
which is not a small company the it is
about 2000 people
can now do because they have
standardized on Taipei they can do 10 to
15 projects whereas before they had one
successful project with 20 30 Pilots a
year
so that's a bit the the background
behind it so when we look at python we
decided let's do all this application in
Python we noticed two big holes in the
python ecosystem one was the the GUI the
other one was the the core the the the
execution side
so on the GUI side
I tried to map you know and it's not all
in there it's a very rich like a lot of
the Python package world it's very rich
and there's always a new package coming
up
um so on one side you've got really
powerful software
fortunately they require specialist
people who do basically know about
graphical development they either know
JavaScript or they don't mind creating
you know in a project they are
responsible for the graphical side and
you've got a lot of different
products of bloodly bloodly GS bloody
Dash we've got TK enter and some other
backgrounds that's not what we wanted to
do okay
even though they are very powerful you
can build really nice application with
this
but that's
too much energy and we're looking at you
know doing something in low code for
this on the other side you've got widget
libraries some of them are more
sophisticated than others they do a bit
more
we studied also and we used that product
who has used swimlet who has heard about
streamlit okay
we felt completely with trimlet when it
came to deploying the application the
event Loop basically
is a nightmare
you can't have it's not a multi-user
environment doesn't work on Jupiter
notebook it doesn't scale there's a
flickering effect which you start using
it
with a bit of data
and so on and so forth so we were very
heavy users of swim meet and we decided
not to use it so
hence the creation of taipai GUI here
on the back end it was all about you
know creating pipelines that could do
more could do us several things so first
the pipeline concept building pipelines
executing Pipelines
and you will I will show you how to do
that with the concept of doing it simply
a short learning curve okay
airflow is not a short running curve
okay it's it's fairly complicated we
want it also to have some of the
features of uh you know versioning that
you can find in ml flow for instance why
to have another package for
you know all these things
scenario management that's typically
something that
our pipelines are scenario enabled so
you can play with different versions
different execution of your scenario by
changing a parameter we call this
scenarios
so it's the same concept if you want
that you have in machine learning they
call it experiment
except that here when you have an end
user
he doesn't know what an experiment is he
wants to change some of the parameters
and run the algorithm again so that's
what we call scenarios
caching of course in a simple way
if you try to do caching in a lot of
these existing it's very complicated
here it's it's extremely simple
plus some other facilities that
we we provide here so that that's these
are the two packages again it's open
source you can do peep install type I
and you get uh these systems so now what
I'm going to do is show you a bit of
code again it's low code so it will not
be uh
shouldn't be scary for any anybody here
so the first concept
that we see here in fact I can start by
just showing you this okay so think of
type I GUI as an extended
markdown okay so this is a markdown
after you have imported installed it you
use the GUI
it's just a markdown string here that
you pass you know I can remove the
parameter here it's not needed
and we're going to run this
okay so when I execute this
you basically
will it will pin off a web a web server
and you will see your markdown appear
on that page here okay so nothing this
is in italic as mentioned in the in the
markdown
I could refresh the server each time but
I'm going to run it
so here what you see is the first
object type by GUI object so it's
basically indicated with those
less and greater signs
and everything else inside this device
is divided or with pipelines by pipe
sorry
the first is always a python object so
it could be an integer a dictionary data
frame an Empire arrays
a lot of different types of objects
on the second field is always the type
of Graphics you want them to show
so here it's a text here it's a slider
and after that it shows the different
properties that you associate
and when it gets longer you can put them
in in a dictionary so that it's lighter
okay so let's let's run this
sorry I'm going to stop this
you can notice also that the syntax is
highlighted so the kind of syntax
Checker that you have on visual code
with
also the code
how do you call this you you it auto
it finds for you all the names
automatically
so it saves you time when you do the the
coding
and you see the interaction I didn't
need to do anything
the the two objects are directly
connected
it's just to show you a little bit of
the interaction that you can build
because that's usually the time where
it's uh
you can spend a lot of time on the third
example here
something a bit bigger where we
not not much so one thing I've added
here is a chart which is a line chart
where I pass the data and in this case
data is just a list
which is in fact the output of a sine
curve here
okay the sine curve returns basically a
list of points
and I'm going to display that as a line
chart
so I could have directly
not use this
on call directly instead of data called
the signs function and put it in there
and that's all what my program would
have done
or I can create a kind of callback here
if this variable
that this change is called Decay which
is here
let's recompute the science function so
basically whenever you change the slider
recompute the
sine function
so that's what you're going to see
sorry for that to do that
so by the way all of this works on
notebooks
in fact that's the only graphical
tool that you can use to build you know
a bit more complex than just the widgets
within a notebook
okay so here again
it's not to make anything fancy here you
just have the the interaction that we're
looking for here you've got a whole
whole range of objects so the
documentation of course is online you've
got all the different objects that exist
all the plotly graphics are mapped also
there exists you can bring your own
Graphics there's an API also to bring
your your own Graphics inside and you've
got the the what we call the layout if
you want
to Define how your pages look like
when you build your graphics
you have some other
demos I will show you the demo maybe a
little bit later again my purpose here
was to show you more the interaction not
to show you something pretty or nice
now let's move to the next uh
topic
which is type by core
so
currently you have two choices when you
build a pipeline
either you're coded in Python
or you use a graphical editor
and we do provide an extension
of so here you have your config you have
an extension here
which shows you under your preferred ID
so in this case visual code
an editor where you can create data
nodes in blue tasks in Red so of course
these tasks are directly pointing to
your Java code that's inside the ID
that's the the principle here okay
so this is a pipeline so again you can
create
all this this is another pipeline that
also feeds into this one
so you can create that graphically and
save it
and it serves as automl file okay which
is typically a read format for
configuring uh it's like yaml if you
want for those who have not it's a
it looks like
something like
like this for instance
okay
that's a readable format that
corresponds to your graph here
so when you are building a pipeline
like here
here I'm doing it in Python so I have to
do step by step I create My First Data
node which is a CSV type
there is a scoping concept to to decide
you know whether this data node is
available for all my pipelines only
certain pipelines and scenarios and all
these things so it's a scoping concept
but you have all different types of
readers and writers for SQL no SQL
sparkhead
tensorflow format you have also a
generic reader writer that you can
create yourself
to create your own data node a data node
is not may not only be data it could be
a parameter if you look at
uh if I go back here
this is is just an integer
which could be a parameter that you get
from the interface from the end user
front ends okay
and this is how we would create
scenarios for instance the end user
would modify the day from which you want
to predict
so it's a prediction task here
and that would create another scenario
automatically so it's the same pipeline
but different version of the pipeline
with different parameters
okay so the scenario is really inside
the concept of pipeline now that's why
we say our pipeline as scenario enabled
okay so
um
yes so let's go back to the
to the code for this particular program
so here we created another
uh all the data nodes that I have some
of them are data output
averaged
the pipeline and I say which tasks are
going to the pipeline it creates that
automatically the sequence and
everything you don't have to worry
because of the so instead of writing all
this
the alternative is just to load the
graphics to load the configuration file
that was saved previously from your
graphics from your pipeline okay so your
code will be only load
the pipeline
from the thumbnail file and execute what
is needed you can execute the whole
pipeline part of the pipeline one task
in the pipeline
that's your your decision
okay
so that's that's what
the options that you have here either to
code everything in python or just trade
graphically your pipeline load the
pipeline that you have created through
the graphics as a config file and
execute what is needed
so here what we'll get executed is the
whole Pipeline with and we are going to
print the output which is a set of
predictions it's very simple prediction
it doesn't matter really what what these
tasks do so what I'm going to do is just
run this
keep in mind that I did run this before
it was wrong just before I came here
around this particular
thing and you see here
sorry let me run it twice so that I'm
sure
what I want to show you
appears
you see the first one so there are two
jobs there were two tasks so when you
execute the task it trades a job so you
have this capability of you know the
Precedence the parallelism that can
occur
uh it's inbuilt inside type by core and
the first one is Skip because nothing
has changed so I don't need to run it
I see so many times data scientists you
know writing the code and depending
where they are
they actually say oh I'm here if so they
say I don't need to run this code so
they modify the code to say I just want
to run it
this way if they were to use pipelines
it would be easier the whole reason
usually for pipelines is to in fact
there are two reasons one is the caching
mechanism so that you can run the same
thing and don't worry what to run not to
run
on the second thing you can run you can
work with the team you can share the
pipeline and share the task between uh
between people
okay so that's
one other thing let me look at the time
how much time do I have
okay good
so
um
yeah so of course the core
works
of course in notebooks or not books it's
less of an issue here
um
one thing I would like to say also
coming back to the graphics I forgot to
mention
is the same here there are capabilities
for Big Data
for instance in the graphics we have
special filters
if you try to load in a line chart three
million points
your program will collapse any any
Python program will collapse
so what you want to do is actually do
something a bit smarter so we do provide
filters smart filters for instance on
the line chart you can say use this
filter I want to see 2000 points only
and please remove all the points but
only the points that modify the list the
shape of the Curve
and that's extremely useful when you are
analyze from since
data from iot or this kind of thing
where you have a lot of points
so you have this capability for lunch
for line charts for Scatter Plots also
where you can use something smarter than
just shading when you are really
overwhelmed with the number of points so
there are capabilities inside type GUI
for Big Data
on type by core it's usually what people
use these days more and more people use
tools like all packages like dusk or
modding
um
less unless people use Spark
that's what we noticed but the software
basically can read
We have basically a data nodes that can
be packet but that can be also different
formats from dusk or modding
any of you are using dasco mode in for
instance
okay
and anybody who is on
spark 4B data ah what have I said here
foreign
yeah so
well anyway that's that's what the
Nvidia people told us
yeah we we do a lot of work with Nvidia
uh we're fairly complementary for what
they do with the Cuda different Tudor
levels and so on so they
really do
and introduce us also to their large
customers where we build graphics and
all this stuff with with them one thing
that I want to note also is that we are
a starter but we have done things a bit
the other way around
the fact that we are not as young as
most of you guys also is a sometimes has
some advantages we had very strong
contacts with large companies so the
software has been built with McDonald's
with Andrea Marche with Samsung with our
solar meter so very large companies that
really gave us a lot of feedback and a
mixed bag for instance a company there
were some finance company that were
extra in fact a lot of the finance
company are extremely sophisticated with
the usage of python they know everything
that
it's quite incredible how much they they
use python
uh associated general we're talking
about two to three hundred users for
instance of python uh JPMorgan we talked
to them uh two weeks ago in New York
City that's
it's really incredible and so these
people are really
into into Python and we have the Other
Extreme
which are people who just get their feet
wet with python a little bit
or nothing or they are thinking about it
some of them because they have no choice
how they feel they feel that way and
they look at type I as an easier way to
get into the these uh these kind of
applications
okay so do I have time for a demo seven
me yes I do
so
um
so we are open source
um
you can get everything you need on the
website documentation
demos tutorials and so on
for the risk of looking a bit too salesy
to you guys
I have to tell you that the
pipeline editor is in beta
at the moment it's going to be released
in January okay towards the second half
of January okay
um
so on the website which you have here
so you have the documentation online
you've got to getting started and
everything and you have demos
and I will show you a demo which is not
particularly sexy I mean it's nothing
fancy about this one what's really sexy
it was it was developed in a couple of
days by somebody who knew nothing about
Taipei zero okay brand student brand new
student data scientist not a graphic
Guys somebody who basically that is with
python
and no experience
so I'm going to choose this demo
which is also a little bit different
than a standard machine learning stuff
but it shows all the concepts
that exists
so I will call this
Eindhoven
and
okay so what you see here
is a very simple
problem
which is about production planning so it
will be a bit of a change from again
from the forecasting classification
anything
it's a factory that has two products I
think it's a wooden they make wooden
chairs and tables
these two products this is the demand
over the next 11 months okay for the two
products so each month there is a
particular demand and they need to come
up with a production plan to meet that
demand
so you've got a graphics that has been
built
you've got you know different tables
that correspond to the initial stock at
during the current month the initial
production level for the current month
under demand not in the curve that you
saw but as a table here
foreign
so what I'm going to do is to create uh
first a scenario here so when I create a
scenario because the model is quite
simple there are only two products
it's going to create to read the data
that is needed load the data
so it runs the whole Pipeline and here
called the algorithm the algorithm is an
optimization model it's mathematical
optimization and it finds the optimal
solution
to meet two objectives
one is to minimize back order costs
basically you cannot meet the demand on
time so you're late if you try to
minimize that on the opposite which is
you you purchase too much for a product
for the demand that you have so these
are kind of two objectives that are
opposite
and it and it has computed the the
result you can see that it's doing
something not too stupid uh if you look
for instance at this Graphics which is
the final product which is I think the
chair here
or the table so you see two curves here
the blue curve is actually the
production of that particular
product the product finish product a
which is the chair
you can see that it respect the maximum
capacity that it's a constraint you
cannot produce more than that every
month
but it was smart enough to over produce
compare with the demand so here it
creates stock because it knows the
demand is going to be higher here so
it's smart it's doing the right stuff
and I've created a scenario for with all
the results the value
of these two objectives now I want to do
this play around thing that the end user
like to do
which is to change something so let's go
back to the table and I'm going to
change the capacity for instance
okay make it a bit smaller
I could re-optimize the current scenario
but I'm going to create a different
scenario now so the same pipeline that
shown some parameters
arms hurry around and I have a slightly
different value
of course the next thing I want to do
after creating a few scenario
and
by the way you noticed yeah I will do
that later
you can select so zero scenario two
scenario one
and you can compare the two
according to two objectives so one is
better than the other
and you can compare that for a scenario
to scenario or over time so when you
code that in Python it's extremely
simple because we have the concept of
scenario we have the concept of Cycles
here
so it makes your life
kind of busy as a developer here I want
to look at what happened over the
because I've run that for several months
so you can see the kpi over time and for
this I will extract from each cycle the
cycle here is a monthly cycle
I will extract what we call
the primary scenario you can see that's
the scenario
in fact
that
two scenario that's that's this one this
is the one with the flag
which is that's the so you don't you
don't need to use scenario by the way if
you don't want to use scenario you are
free not to use them
but here we are saying that for that
month that's the scenario that's going
to be published that's the official one
and you can send it of course
so all this way of working which is
really uh
what happens very often for instance in
McDonald's every week they need to
project forecast sometimes it's every
month so every hour depends on the
situation all of this is also available
within the type I core system
okay
so that shows you what the kind of
application that can be built and again
that was developed in two days
okay
so that's again it's
I don't want you to necessarily
understand what's behind it
or to uh say it's not so nice so it's
just the time it takes to to do the the
development without having Specialists
for everything
okay so that's
um got some other charts that you can
see and save on and so on
I don't know they used to be a buy no it
doesn't work
okay so
um
so how are we doing here
five seconds
who said I wasn't
good okay perfect
question time
question you want a microphone or
yep I think that's fine
will be the difference in deploying type
bike apparently streaming because it's
flask application yes on the background
yeah yes
it's it's not only the deployment file
it's the the capabilities that you have
so first of all
I told you it's it's
a single user
so here I can launch for you for
instance two different runs of the same
URL
it's the same application
to you two different users if I modify
your
if I do something and one it will not be
reflected on the other one if you do
that with streamlit it's the same thing
so if you have two users you have to
duplicate completely the execution of
the thing but the most difficult thing
in streamlined is the event Loop which
is how the product has been built
so if you have some input data or
something the data will not be
persistent so it will erase the data
of course you have some caching
mechanism but it becomes a nightmare and
with side effects like flickering
the third issue is scaling not even not
even with big data you start having a
few pages
with a bit of data say 10 000 lines and
a bit of events
starts to and if you have something even
bigger than at the end of it and it
doesn't work on some Jupiter notebooks
and so on and so forth so
that's that's I mean it was a great
product at the start
we really I was the second user and I
know the the CEO is the son of one of my
very good friends
but you know
when he was like I talked to him at some
stage and tell him you know you have to
to do something you are going to you are
hitting here the ceiling you I can't use
your product I was a user at that time I
was dealing with
applications with end users
I said yeah there's no way I'm going to
use unless you modify and you refuse and
he was already in talk with snowflake so
it was too late
so that that's the story behind it but
we we absolutely tried very hard
to use simulate uh
but and it's very hard to change that's
the way the internals do work there are
a lot of things on Taipei also that are
optimized for the event management
so for instance we have customers you
will never be able to do that in any way
it's a notebook issue but you could have
your a platform like uh I don't know for
those who are using that data breaks for
instance you can data breaks running
some graphics redirect that with NG rock
on your local screen and it's great
you can do this kind of thing with a
with type I
so
you're talking about something like GIS
kind of thing or
yeah so at the moment we are very much
the product is new it's uh six months
old
we are
built on top of plotly
so all the plastic thing that you can do
so there are some mapping capabilities
um
so most of the plotly object will be
mapped in January now we have about 50
percent of them mapped
we have an API also to bring external
Graphics into the software okay and we
are also listening to our customers so
some of them are extremely specific from
some of them want
not to read only gun shells but a fairly
complex gunshots with interaction and
this kind of things for those who have
worked with gunshots know what I'm
talking about these are very complex
things to do we are building that also
with some of the customers so if you
have something extremely specific about
some of the graph Graphics that you
would like to see you can either use our
existing API
JavaScript API or we may get if we see
that there is a potential for more users
we are happy to to work on it as well
but mapping we have a lot of customers
using it for mapping
more in the supply chain context you
know with typical stuff you know you got
the map you've got a layer of
warehouses factories links different
thicknesses that's
but it's more or less plotly at this
stage which is you know fairly large in
scope but again you can you can bring
additional
widgets from your liking
yes
lying on the recent
both both are possible
you can you can obviously what I showed
you here was running locally but you can
run that on a server
in your company or
so we are
um
this capability of multi-tenant
capabilities is something that we don't
know at the moment
uh uh but we are working with uh
the company that is special it's going
to be built on top on existing software
that does that very well
so we are we are not yet uh into that
that level
oh no no these are completely different
packages you can use the graphics
without you mean the pipeline the
pipeline Graphics right
and also if I disable my pipeline
through care draw or some in some other
manner
oh yeah absolutely the graphics is uh
independent from the the type I core
absolutely
there's no it's as I said two
independent packages
and it will remain that way
you made a comparison
yeah so
sure so radio is very much machine
learning uh oriented we are much wider
than that
uh no it's it's a good tool but it's we
never compete with radio
um
again we look at applications that you
want to build radio as a it could be
some overlap but it's it's free for
machine learning and it's usually
even more local than we are it's
straightforward yeah and it's very close
to
almost like a hugging face kind of thing
but yeah it's we have a wider scope than
radio
thank you
[Applause]